i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked the legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key okay
because this is a movie with cheesy
jokes and cheesy puns i'm gonna ask a
really cheesy question to get things
started
there's a cockatoo in this movie hello
yeah and or three yeah
[Applause]
oh that's the first joke you've done
well really
okay wow that was good cocker three
we would have known that was
amazing good i'm talking about rosita
that particular cockatoo
frankie owes me money franco francoise
so the cockatoo repeats the phrase
that the cockatoo hears the most which
is frank owes me money if you each had a
cockatoo on your shoulder for a day what
phrase do you think we would hear
the most coming out of you what do you
think uh
rosita would repeat
i need
um don't
what would mine say i need to pee
i hear myself say that all the time i
need to pee yes
it's an announcement it's always very
loud
is that all right i need to pee i hear
myself saying that like
what would you all say come on i see you
stewing those blue eyes are like
early bird gets the gains gets the games
day not only is that good yeah you say
that every day
yeah can you not tell from his physique
yes
how do i top that um uh i don't know
um i think the the opposite like i want
to take a nap
i want to take a nap yeah take a nap
yeah okay
i'm a big rapper thank you
more corny i decided to be more even
more horny you are known for your one
eyebrow raise i don't know if the rest
of the cast can do one eyebrow
raise oh i mean it's like that was good
imagine just doesn't move i'm like
both is that one that's good great
oh there we go oh jack
oh wow look at this it's a sexy eyebrow
that was very nice wow yeah but it's
still going you now have a biting of the
lip is that the new one eyebrow
definitely actually please people's lips
do not go into a wide man's place if you
do it
your legs played as you did it
oh god just pop that cockatoo away
so i know that you all went to dwayne's
gym
it was very rarefied air that you were
in because not very many people have
been invited
because they're true no one
exactly but jack um is quite focused on
his glutes
and so he was impressed with how many
glute machines
there were yeah i really just focus on
the glutes i've let everything else
completely fall by the way that's
actually why he's sitting so high
yeah i can't sit in the front because if
i tense my glutes you won't be able to
see the rest of the cast
but for for those of us that will never
be invited in what is it like
it's actually really serene and
beautiful and vast
and very clean and he always knew when
i'd been in there because i'm
not she left everywhere baby weights
left everywhere
like little nothing wiped down sweat
everywhere
and and he was like do you clean up like
what's your issue
yeah so she but the truth is she did she
invited herself and she said hey can i
come over and work out at the gym uh
and i was like sure
do you know my favorite thing is that he
has this kind of motivation blackboard
that he writes stuff on
and i would leave him the most appalling
messages for him to walk into
inappropriate draw the most
inappropriate things
i have to stare at and go what is that
and then
talk a threesome listen a cocker three
and it's like and it was great
she drew this hairy doughnut and i was
like what is
that i'll tell her what's a hairy
doughnut i mean
you explained i don't even know the
glues
it's between the glutes like i'm oh no
i'm gonna ask you all to play imagineer
for a second we know that this is a
famous disney ride it turned into a
movie i want you all to choose something
you've done in your careers either a
series or a film
that you think would make a cool ride at
disney
i feel edger tomorrow would make a very
cool
mimics and you have to avoid the mimics
and maybe you're on like a roller
coaster
and it feels like you're going to get
your head spliced off with a mimic but
you're not
and then tom cruise is there personal
friend
friend to kind of greet you right as you
get off the right
like that sounds good i like it yeah tom
will be there in person
what about you guys edgar wow um
actually it was uh really brave yeah
exactly yeah the break is good
yeah point blank oh absolutely yeah
boring break i mean
and and with all the you know this the
snowboarding the surfing
you know the the the proximity flight
that would be incredible too yeah that's
cool
there um and um and yeah what are you
steering on what would you do
um well maybe frozen obviously i was in
frozen so no
do you tell us about that in frozen yeah
but i could be part of that ride i could
just be there not speaking
and be frozen you can literally be
frozen
frozen there dressed as a big fat troll
but not saying anything great
either that or maybe travels with my
father which could be like jungle cruise
except you're trapped on the boat with a
very rude geriatric englishman
without you me yeah movies i've done
manchurian candidate i think oh wow
i think you were in that no that wasn't
me harry potter harry potter
harry potter probably
harry bottom
so the sets in this film are
unbelievable i know that there was a set
actually built in kauai
pretty close to your home yes um
first of all just sort of like the scope
of walking into those sets and then
after that i have an idea
for you dwayne okay but just to talk
about a little bit about the
sure the scope and the scale of these
sets were spectacular
um we wanted to
create as much practicality as we
possibly could we we shot in kauai
the majority of our movie then we moved
our entire production to sound stages in
georgia
and um we were on thousands and
thousands of acres
where they we our designers just
built these spectacular
[Music]
buildings and sets the beginning of
jungle cruise is not cgi
that is real sets um down on the amazon
and there was a beautiful reservoir down
there so
we really wanted to make sure that the
the the sets and the scale of our movie
uh reflected uh
that of the of the ride um and so here's
my idea
okay you are like the next walt disney
you already have the set there
you love hawaii next theme park in
hawaii
build it around that great idea do we
like it you could have a fountain with
terramotta tequila
as you walk in you can have cheap meals
served everywhere around the park what
do we think about this idea that's a
great idea do i get a cut you do
well we'll talk off camera okay
do we like this idea or run the donut
store
yeah i love it that's a great idea
i want to talk about the kiss in this
movie and that was hot right
it was really hot white hot it was super
hot
it got a big applause no i just hated it
he said it was like watching his parents
kiss by the end he was so mortified
it was a very
everyone cheered and you're so invested
it was beautiful but yeah just on set
because
we've grown so close and i know you
suddenly smooched i was a bit like
you're like no but jack i heard you were
actually making sound effects when they
were on set going like ooh
ah it was he was under his breath going
yeah yeah got a bit of that johnson yes
get a bit of that johnson
some of it takes place underwater how
how romantic
is it kissing underwater it looks
beautiful but is it in
actuality it's so beautiful it was
so beautiful watching it on the day you
can't see much
you cannot see anything it's very murky
our eyes were like
lobster red by the end of shooting we
shot it for like two days the whole tank
sequence
um it it was beautiful to see it back
like
done because when you walk underwater
you cannot see anything
and you it was a bit scary at first
because you are kind of you really are
trapped
in this thing wow it was open on top and
so but i couldn't see anything so you'd
hold your breath for as long as you
could and they'd so
you go down with your goggles on and
they'd point out what you had to see and
you were like okay i think i have it you
take one more gasp on your respirator
thing
and then you take it off and suddenly
you can't see anything and you're kind
of blindly trying to find the lever and
then
and then when you're running out of
breath i would just kind of put my arms
up and
people would reach down and just pull
you out because i couldn't see my way
out
so from most romantic kiss ever most
remember
how good they are as actors as well that
whole sequence had so much in it and
there was so much like nuance and there
was
humor it was romantic i did like the bit
where i pulled your head and smashed
your head against you well it was so
funny and so good when i went
and when you first got my case no
trust
look it was it was great you know the
those
awesome what i liked about it at the
time of his life you know what i mean
it was better
better kisser yeah oh yeah
oh god
and she's taller than both of them too
that's true okay we'll leave it there
edgar
your first disney movie yeah seeing
yourself
in all of that glory on the big screen i
didn't hate this villain i didn't hate
him
you feel for him you understand i mean
it happens i mean things didn't work out
and then he
crossed over to the dark side i mean
haven't we all
at some point you know i mean that
that's uh become riddled with snakes
yeah at some point at some point uh but
no
i i i i i loved it i love i love the
whole experience and
and as i said in other interviews it's
just it's just very special i mean this
is
this is the most iconic entertainment
universe in history
disney and just to be part of it and to
and to
you know to to to be to be part of a
of a movie that that belongs to a legacy
that has
in in in my opinion i can speak i'm sure
on behalf of a lot of people around the
world i mean our our taste
and our love for cinema has been shaped
by disney
in so many ways so it is very special it
is very special
yeah and i'm sure that for for for many
of us here and um
and and around the world it's really
special i i saw the movie two nights ago
and i go and i went on on jungle cruise
on the right for the first time
two nights ago and i love theme parks
and i love to be in disney i love to be
here it's um
since since i was a kid i mean the first
part that i visited was the one in
orlando
because i come from venezuela so more
the east coast but being here at
disneyland is really special and to have
the premiere here
to be having this conversation here is
very iconic i mean i'm i'm sure i will
look back
in in 20 30 years to this moment and i
would be very very happy
very proud that's a great answer well
said and you do feel it being here and i
wanted to ask all of you i know you got
to see some cool rooms behind the scenes
scenes that are rooms that people don't
normally get to see so did you all get
to experience anything really cool
get brought behind the scenes here at
disneylander at disney world and
uh share what those things are before we
went into the movie emily and i had an
opportunity to
go to um where the hidden imagineers
all work and that was amazing really an
amazing
experience because it's it's in that
building and we saw the first
map of disneyland like that very first
like layout and it was
so it was huge and it's behind the vault
yeah they have it protected and yeah it
was really
incredible just to see the craftsmanship
and the care yeah
and the magic it's like they want to
kidnap you with magic and imagination
and
that's all they do all day is conjure up
extraordinary ways to make people feel
joyful
it's just it was beautiful and edgar as
you were talking about you know just how
special this experience is like
it's just like it's once in a career if
you guys absolutely you know that to
have something like this
and when you're here and especially i
feel like when
when disney does it right hey
it is they get it right yeah you know
yeah thankfully it feels like we did
jungle cruise right and it just where it
hits on all those
special unique one-of-a-kind disney
elements did you really have walt's
picture in your trailer
i did as inspiration yeah and it's still
there
wow it's a picture of walt and his head
and
emily yes because she's 87 years old
just a huge poster in here it's a little
bit strange but um
on the ceiling yeah there you are
inspiration i guess i have i have a
really cool picture of walt
um a few days before the park opened in
1955
in the jungle cruise in the boat with
his lead engineer
and elite imagineer and engineer uh
it's a really really cool picture and
that was the inspiration everybody
just the term right imagineer isn't it
right
is that great just to have just the
terminologies to have
i mean i'm sure that term was created
here imagining yeah
yes have just that tells you how how
how remarkable and how iconic everything
is just to have yeah
that that that word as part of
you know of of the english language
imagineer it's a beautiful thing
i know jack you're a big disney file
you're a big disney fan even before
this did you audition for lion king is
that true or are you really
no i didn't
my one of my stand-up shows i ended with
a lion king musical that i put a one-man
lion king musical like
myself wow probably a copyright
infringement so i shouldn't say that
i've changed some of the names of the
characters
i've always been obsessed with disney i
love the disney movies like
your favorite lion king was my favorite
wow what do you love about lion king
i just think it's it's just got
everything with fur it's just
totally great villainy and um
i'm still not really over them if that's
the thing but oh god it's coming back to
me now it's fine it's fine
he's in the stars yeah um but yeah and
you know to what these guys have been
saying like the chance to be able to
maybe create a film that's going to
resonate with a a new audience and
and be an iconic film for a new
generation of disney fans
like it's not lost on us the
significance of that absolutely
and that you know was always what we
were striving to try and achieve with
jungle cruise and i
really think the finished product is
something that is quite magical and so
hopefully there'll be you know kids
watching it now and and
in 20 years time still talking about it
that's how it feels it feels like a
throwback to the films that we loved
growing up absolutely
it feels like a film that i've already
watched it three times now and it gets
better and better
every single time i watch it i think
it's completely iconic
instantly and i think that's a testament
to all of you obviously your chemistry
not just the two of you together all of
us but yeah everybody
all of you so talk a little bit about
like when do you when do you know when
do you know i knew when i met him like i
think
you know we had a dinner about three
months before we started
once i was cast and involved and
the moment i met him it was like we
ping-pong back and forth the rapport was
so
instantaneous and i think if you have
that naturally with someone
and i knew we were going to have fun
together we laughed that whole time over
dinner we were already giving each other
it was just it was great and then
i think if you have that it does sort of
by osmosis sort of carry into the screen
and i think if you have a natural ease
with someone then
you can stretch those scenes around and
they become really free-spirited and you
can improv and it's the same with jack
who's just so
ready to kind of come in guns blazing
and just try anything and we had this
very trusting
environment where you could throw
anything against the wall and it was fun
to see what end up
ended up sticking it was just it was
easy
and chemistry is so strange it's such a
strange thing it's very difficult to
kind of
um talk about what it is but i always
feel chemistry is like it's not this
person and this person it's the space
between them and that's chemistry and
the reason it's called chemistry is
because there's so many components that
come into whether it's there or not
and i think ultimately we all just had
such ease with each other such trust
with each other
and we all have a very similar sense of
humor which is usually in the toilet
which none of uh we've all been enjoying
you know not just within the movie
disney
loving it the disney execs are loving
it so because i'm so confident there's
going to be more and more
and more of these films sequels where
would each of you
like to see this movie go what would you
what is your dream scenario where are we
showing up next time in the world i want
to go to like
asia or something like yeah it feels
like it
yeah that would be incredible the thames
or the thames
dj mrs twickenham tj loves london
there's so many amazing rivers and
around the around
around the world uh um of course you
started with the one that is closest to
my heart which is the amazon
river um because i come from an
amazonian country from venezuela
um and and and we're all very happy
because it was beautiful it's gorgeous i
had
i i i hadn't been um
in awe watching a movie in a very long
time
and i cannot believe because i i can
really pull myself out of
the position as an actor and i and
really watched the movie
and i was in awe that scene the i don't
know if i can we
yeah yeah when i saw what you guys did
in hawaii
the the the the you guys in your boat
the submarine and then yeah
because i wasn't there i i was in that
location i was like what
what is going on i mean like all the
elements and most of that was mechanical
it was nice i was you know because that
is the thing one of the things that i
found
so incredible about this film and i get
that question asked a lot because of
you know all the cgi involved in my
character i never saw the snakes but i
was on those sets and every time we
fought and every and whatever
our scenes were we were there that was
not that movie that we were surrounded
by green screen and acting opposite a
tennis ball
no we were there were people there and
we were doing it those those sets were
built
yeah so the production design on this
movie is incredible it's like
i love cinema and this is the i mean the
magic of cinema
is so palpable in this movie that is
incredible
it is amazing what you guys did in in
kauai was
unbelievable yeah and um and and of
course it would be amazing to take that
magic
around the world to all the you know the
most iconic you know
rivers you know uh around around the
world which also will
the nile could be amazing
dwayne will let you uh finish and then
also was this film i mean if you want to
answer where would you like to see it go
and was this because you're a producer
on this film
seeing it come to fruition was it like a
dream come true this is disney it's all
about dreams this 100 was like a dream
come true
the movie was a dream the finished
product yes and finally after seeing it
you know you hope you make something
good you surround yourself with the best
people
in the business the best crew
storytellers and you cross your fingers
you put in the work
so we did deliver uh a great movie
um but i and i've told this story before
when i first started in hollywood with
the scorpion king i went to go see
my own movie which was so surreal and i
saw a
trailer for pirates at that time with
johnny depp who was the biggest movie
star in the world
i was blown away right it's like
edgar was saying when you know you get
lost you know when you're in the cinema
you just
get so immersed in this and i was so
blown away by that trailer
and i thought wow i would live i have a
half the career
that you know that guy has maybe one day
i can
be in a movie like this that's based off
an iconic disney ride so
many years later here we are i have the
best cast in the world and we made a
great movie based off an iconic disney
ride and
so it's been a dream come true
oh my gosh
allusion torpedo
you